j'informe le sénat que des candidatures
pour siéger au sein de la commission des
affaires économiques commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées de la commission des
finances et de la commission des lois
ont été publiées ces candidatures seront
ratifiés si la présidence n'a pas reçu
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
prévue par notre règlement g informe
également le sénat que des candidatures
pour siéger au sein des commissions
mixtes paritaires changer pour poser un
texte sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi ordinaire et
du projet de loi organique pour la
confiance dans l'institution judiciaire
ont été publiés ces candidatures sont
également pâti fier si la présidence n'a
pas reçu d'opposition dans le délai
d'une heure l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
instaurant la vaccination obligatoire
contre sarko 2 présenté par monsieur
patrick kanner monsieur bernard genier
madame marie pierre de la gontrie madame
monique lubin et plusieurs de leurs
collègues à la demande du groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
et dans la discussion générale la parole
est à monsieur kaner autant et
proposition de loi pour dix minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mais monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous nous retrouvons
donc aujourd'hui pour débattre de cette
proposition de loi instaurant la
vaccination obligatoire contre le
sarcome deux déposés par le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
alors que ce matin mais monsieur le
ministre monsieur véran présenter sauf
erreur de ma part le 11e projet de loi
d'urgence sanitaire en conseil des
ministres
l'examen de notre texte permet de
nouveau à la chambre haute de se pencher
sur ce qui nous a mobilisé de nombreuses
fois depuis un an et demi l'épidémie que
8,19 à frapper durement notre pays et le
monde entier la crise n'est pas encore
derrière nous auquel cas cette
proposition d'ailleurs n'aurait aucun
objet aucun sens mais nous commençons à
voir un certain recul dont nous devons
tirer des enseignements qui doivent nous
guider mes chers collègues je précise
tout de suite qu avec ce texte notre
groupe ne souhaite pas distribuer de
bons ou de mauvais point sur la gestion
de la crise
comme toujours que ce soit lors de
l'examen d état d'urgence sanitaire des
débats 50-1 des lois de finances
rectificative et j'en passe nous
souhaitons après à la discussion des
mesures qui nous paraissent les plus
justes et les plus efficaces dans ce
cadre nous continuons à dire ce que nous
disons depuis plusieurs mois cette crise
peut être géré avec clarté et
transparence de la clarté sur les
objectifs visés sur les mesures à
prendre pour
régler finalement cette question
fondamentale et rassurer nos concitoyens
de la transparence concernant les prises
de décisions ces deux éléments sont
indispensables pour créer une relation
de confiance entre les pouvoirs publics
et les français cette confiance est
nécessaire pour que l'adhésion aux
mesures sanitaires soient massives cet
effet d'entraînement est d'ailleurs la
seule voie pour que nous sortions
définitivement de cette épidémie nous
faisons donc le choix de cette clarté de
cette transparence conformément à ce que
nous défendons depuis juillet dernier et
la mise en place du pass sanitaire le
gouvernement en associant vaccination et
conditionnement de la vie sociale à la
présentation d'un pass sanitaire a exigé
des français une obligation de
vaccination 1
direct kindy et n'assume pas son nom
nous pensons que l'obligation vaccinale
doit donner lieu un débat public et doit
assumer sa nature c'est l'exigence
démocratique que le groupe socialiste
écologiste et public importe à travers
cette proposition de loi par ailleurs
cette vaccination obligatoire existe
déjà pour certaines professions et nous
ne croyons pas que la lutte contre la
pandémie puisse reposer sur quelques
professions qu'elle puisse se découper
en tranches finalement nous avons
applaudi les soignants tous les soirs à
20h lorsque nous étions confinés nous ne
pouvons pas les pointer du doigt une
fois des comptines et la crise sanitaire
impose une solidarité nationale la
vaccination est un devoir citoyen qui
incombe à chacun pour se protéger et
protéger les autres
certes monsieur le ministre votre forme
d'obligations masqué a produit ses
effets cet été il faut le reconnaître
elle a permis de briser un premier
plafond de verre vaccinale que nous
sentions poindre plafond de verre qu'il
faisait courir un grand risque à notre
pays en raison de la propagation massive
de ce méchant variant delta aujourd'hui
nous le constatons nous sommes devant un
deuxième plafond de verre avec environ
30000 35000 peut-être primo vaccinés par
jour c'est insuffisant alors que nous
devons encore vaccinés 8 millions de
personnes pour accéder à une immunité
qui nous permettrait d'avancer avec plus
de certitudes que nous n'ayons jamais
eue depuis mars 2020 si nous ne bougeons
pas s'ils ne nous réagissons pas nous
atteindrons un taux de 90% de vacciner à
l'été 2022 trop tard trop tard pour
passer avec sérénité la saison hivernale
propice aux robots épidémique j'y
reviendrai trop lointain pour attester
de l'efficacité d'une stratégie
vaccinale ne passant que par le pass
sanitaires le ralentissement de
l'épidémie semble se confirmer en france
tant mieux mais il faut s'en réjouir et
constater que ce ralentissement est dû
en majeure partie à l'augmentation de
notre taux de couverture vaccinale pour
autant nous ne devons pas baisser la
garde arnaud fontanes et épidémiologiste
à l'institut pasteur nous alerte sur un
potentiel redémarrage de l'épidémie à
l'automne grâce à la vaccination cette
vague si elle a lieu ne devrait pas être
un calque des précédentes pour autant
pour autant elle pourrait quand même
provoqué des dizaines de milliers
d'hospitalisations avec son cortège de
morts de kovy de long et d'embolie
hospitalière cela bat en brèche
l'argument portées par certains qui
prétendent que cette proposition de loi
arrive trop tardivement ce n'est pas
parce que l'aco vide ne tient plus haut
de la fiche depuis plusieurs semaines
qu'elle a pour autant disparu d'ailleurs
chez ministre en excluant toute
adaptation du patiani terre avant la
mi-novembre et en maintenant un cadre
légal permettant d'avoir recours aux
spas sanitaire peut-être jusqu'au 31
juillet 2022 le gouvernement semble
d'ailleurs partagé notre analyse je les
encourage donc à pousser sa réflexion
jusqu'au bout et assumer politiquement
avec nous une vaccination obligatoire et
universel devant le risque je viens
d'évoquer nous pouvons pas rester les
bras ballants avec un pass sanitaire qui
reste un pis-aller bien imparfait car il
comporte des manquements en termes de
réduction de circulation virale en effet
quid des métros des supermarchés des
meetings électoraux cela a été confirmé
par le ministre de l'intérieur récemment
la campagne électorale ne passera pas
par le pass sanitaires autant de trous
dans la raquette sanitaire que viendrait
combler finalement notre proposition de
vaccination obligatoire oui l'obligation
engendre de meilleurs taux de
vaccination c'est un outil qui s'est
toujours avéré efficace
utilisant le comme nous l'avons fait en
1902 avec l'obligation vaccinale pour la
variole j'entends aussi nos concitoyens
qui s'interroge sur le fait d'obliger de
se faire vacciner avec un vaccin qui a
été mis sur le marché la moins d'un an
je préciserai simplement que pour être
commercialisé avec sein doit obtenir une
autorisation de mise sur le marché les
vaccins contre la copie 19 ont été
développés en un temps record certes
mais ils ont satisfait aux différentes
phases d'essai clinique habituellement
exigé et obtenu cette autorisation
ce n'est donc pas un vaccin expérimental
nous suivons simplement les
recommandations des pouvoirs publics
fermons le ban sur ce point là ce que
nous savons en revanche c'est que les
vaccins sont efficaces ils le sont en
particulier pour éviter les formes
graves et les morts
la saturation du système de santé et de
ce fait également les morts indirects
liés à d'autres pathologies une étude
française menée sur 22 millions et 600
mille personnes par épi phare un
groupement d'intérêt scientifique montre
que les vaccinés de plus de 50 ans aux
neuf fois moins de risques d'être
hospitalisées et de mourir par l'aco vie
19,6 elles sont vaccinés nous avons
désormais une solution pour éviter la
saturation hospitalière et avec celle ci
bien sûr le fameux tri terrible des
patients c'est un devoir éthique mais
chaque collègue qui s'impose à nous qui
seraient concernées par cette
vaccination obligatoire les personnes de
plus de 60 ans en priorité plus
vulnérables susceptibles d'être
hospitalisés
bien évidemment nous voulons aussi une
application souple et intelligente de
l'obligation vaccinale
celle ci permettrait d'étendre
progressivement l'obligation par
tranches d'âge ou de l'interrompre
finalement rapidement selon l'évolution
de nos connaissances médicales et
l'apparition peut-être nous l'espérons
de nouvelles thérapies efficaces par
exemple cette vaccination obligatoire
est la seule mesure universelle qui est
aujourd'hui à notre disposition des
publics éloignés de la vaccination
notamment et plus précaires ou ceux qui
ne se sentent pas concernés par le passé
ni terre entreront enfin de plain-pied
dans la stratégie vaccinale française
elle ne sera pas un frein à la les verts
mais sera complémentaire car elle
permettra d'engager un dialogue avec
celles et ceux qui sont encore permettez
moi l'expression dans l'angle mort de la
vaccination reste la question de la
sanction il n'y en a pas dans le texte
d'origine dans notre texte d'origine car
l'expérience prouve que celle annonce
d'une obligation qui amène les
populations agir et non l'annoncent
d'une sanction on le voit certes
peut-être petitement sur le plan
démographique mais on le voit en
nouvelle calédonie où il annonce de
l'obligation a entraîné une hausse de la
vaccination alors qu'il n'y avait pas de
sanction pour la population générale
pour autant un amendement a été déposé
par une grande partie de notre groupe
que je soutiens il vise la mise en place
de sanctions proportionnées à l' inverse
de ce qui était proposé pour le pass
sanitaire concernant le contrôle
question qui nous est fréquemment
demandée il faut également un dispositif
proportionnée plutôt qu'un contrôle
partout tout le temps contre tout ce qui
n'aurait pas le pass sanitaires et bien
nous pensons que un contrôle aléatoire
serait tout à fait efficace je tiens
d'ailleurs à préciser monsieur ministre
nous constatons en tout cas moi je les
constate est une forme de relâchement
dans le contrôle du passé ni terre sur
le terrain des habitudes mauvaises sont
en train d'être prises ni compris chez
les commerçants voient même des
restaurateurs en tout cas le contrôle
aléatoire serait beaucoup plus efficace
et nous pourrions le systématiser dans
les lieux très fréquentés avec une jauge
importante pour conclure mes chers
collègues les principes qui nous ont
amenés à déposer cette proposition de
loi sont simples
l'obligation vaccinale ne doit pas être
et ne sera pas l'alpha et l'oméga de la
lutte contre le virus elle est cependant
une pierre importante fondamentale qu'il
faut additionner à une stratégie plus
globale en ce sens nous continuerons à
nous exprimer monsieur le ministre sur
la levée des brevets sur le dispositif
kovacs qui est loin d'avoir atteint ses
objectifs et sont les engagements
internationaux de la france l'om est ce
par la voix de maria van kerkhove nous
alerte en lisant que nous n'avons pas le
contrôle du virus dans le monde il faut
l'entendre rien que pour la première
semaine d'octobre ont été constatés 3
millions de cas nouveaux de
contamination dans le monde et 54 mille
décès nous continuerons également à
soutenir la recherche sur les
traitements et les mesures sanitaires
tant qu'elles seront nécessaires mais je
le répète la vaccination universelle
obligatoire est la seule solution
efficace pour obtenir une couverture
médicale nécessaire à notre protection
collective avec l'obligation vaccinale
sous réserve l'appairage la réserve
pardon de l'apparition de nouveaux
variants enregistrant un vaccin là covin
peut être réduit à une maladie à bas
bruit avec des résurgences saisonnière
maîtrisé sur le plan sanitaire mes chers
collègues pour toutes ces raisons parce
que nous devons renforcer notre arsenal
sanitaire parce que la vaccination est
un devoir citoyen parce que l'intérêt
général n'est pas la somme des intérêts
particuliers
je vous invite chaleureusement à voter
cette proposition de loi
merci
la parole est aux importants d'atomiser
de la commission des affaires sociales
bernard jomier
[Musique]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission mes chers collègues le prix
nobel de la paix vient d'être décerné à
deux journalistes courageux
l'une d'elles maria rsa apprenant sa
distinction à rappeler qu'un monde sans
fait signifier un monde sans vérité et
sans confiance les fais mes chers
collègues sont devenus des objets de
débats
les fait pas la signification qu'on peut
leur donner les causes qui les détermine
les conséquences qu'on en tire tout cela
devrait être le débat politique mais il
nous faut en ce début de siècle nous
battre simplement pour dire la vérité
des faits et la vérité des faits c'est
que les vaccins contre la copie 19 sont
efficaces comme peu le vaccin l'on était
qu'ils sont sûrs et qui sont notre
meilleure arme pour réduire la pandémie
à l'état d'un bruit de fond sans graves
conséquences économiques sanitaires et
sociales sans eux tout notre pays aurait
subi à l'arrivée du variant delta ce
qu'on subit se donne aux territoires où
les populations sont trop peu vaccinés
il nous faut maintenant avec les vaccins
fournir un dernier effort un effort
collectif en juillet dernier pour
justifier la vaccination obligatoire de
certaines professionnelles contre lacko
vide le gouvernement a mis en avant leur
devoir d'exemplarité leurs
responsabilités et il à vis des
personnes vulnérables face à un virus
imprévisible dont les mutations continue
de menacer la raison dans notre système
de santé est bien la responsabilité de
la lutte contre cette épidémie nos
pauvres au co faut poser évidemment que
sur ces seuls professionnels elle est
bien entendu collective et chacun doit
d'entre nous doit il prendre sa part
cette responsabilité collective elle
comprend le respect des gestes barrières
oui mais la dernière étape pour donner
pour tourner la page de cette épidémie
nous devons la franchir tous ensemble en
mobilisant larmes la plus sûre et la
plus efficace
le vaccin par essence se faire vacciner
un geste solidaire après 117 1000 décès
et un coût de la crise de plus de 400
milliards d'euros pour les finances
publiques
qui parmi nous peut se permettre de
faire l'économie d'un tel geste nous
avons les moyens avec la vaccination de
nous rendre collectivement mètres de
cette épidémie pour la transformer en un
phénomène à bas bruit
contrôlé sur le plan sanitaire une très
grande majorité de français se sont fait
vacciner et il aspire donc légitimement
à ce que les restrictions cesse
cet objectif il est à notre portée si
nous parvenons à court terme un taux
d'immunité d'origine vaccinale ou
naturels d'au moins 90% il nous manque
environ 9 millions de personnes à
immuniser pour atteindre ce niveau de
protection collective et ce n'est pas le
pass sanitaires dont les effets
maintenant s'essouffle considérablement
qui nous permettra d'y parvenir avec
seulement trente mille primo vaccination
par jour maintenant nous ne pouvons
espérer atteindre 90% de la population
vaccinée comme ça a été dit par patrick
kanner avant l'été prochain or d'ici là
la probabilité que nous connaissons une
nouvelle vague existe bel et bien avec
tout ce que cela comporte
d'hospitalisation de décès et de covile
l'ombre même si nous pouvons espérer que
notre système de santé ne serait pas de
nouveaux saturé sommes nous prêts à
prendre ce risque à côté d'une petite
minorité bruyante d'anti vax j'entends
surtout cette majorité de français
qui s'est acquitté de cet acte citoyen
qu'est la vaccination
j'entends les deux français sur trois
qui soutiennent l'obligation vaccinale
universel c'est pourquoi le texte que
nous examinons aujourd'hui propose
inclure dans la liste des vaccinations
obligatoires
la vaccination contre le sar skov 2 tout
en ménageant entièrement au gouvernement
la souplesse réglementaires nécessaires
pour son déploiement en termes de rythme
et de populations à ceux qui opposent
qu'une obligation vaccinale est
inopérante faute de moyens pour en
contrôler le respect je fais appel à
leur mémoire
l'obligation vaccinale c'est vraiment
pas une nouveauté dans notre pays la
variole au début du siècle dernier la
diphtérie le tétanos la tuberculose la
poliomyélite autant de maladies qui
faisait chaque année sensiblement moins
de morts que le coc vide et que nous
avons maîtrisé grâce à la vaccination
obligatoire
quels étaient les sanctions encourues
pour faire respecter ses obligations
vaccinales historique des amendes contre
avant quand contraventionnelle et rien
d'autre
or qui ici peut dire que la vaccination
obligatoire contre ces maladies n'a pas
fonctionné l'existence d'une
contravention implique-t-elle ou
contrôler chaque individu à chaque coin
de rue non et les exemples récents de
l'obligation vaccinale universelle
contre le coc vide en nouvelle calédonie
l'exemple des obligations vaccinales
voter en 2018 montre que la hausse des
personnes vaccinées a été obtenue en
amont de toute sanction je n'ai aucun
regret des propos que j'ai tenus ici
dans cet hémicycle en 2018
face à celles et ceux qui rejetaient
déjà l'obligation vaccinale car les
faits ont parlé et la vérité des faits
oui la vérité des faits encore une fois
c'est que les objectifs ont été atteints
et rapidement et que nous sommes un en
phase d'éradication de ces maladies
contre lesquels notre lit plus tu
patines et stagner s'enliser ce sont des
enfants qui ont été sauvées et ce sont
des enfants qu'elles seront épargnés de
lourdes complications
il nous faut donc regarder au delà de la
sanction comme gage d'effectivité et au
delà de la contravention la mise en
place d'un passeport vaccinale seul aux
modèles récemment décidé en écosse c'est
à dire limité à certaines situations à
haut risque pourrait effectivement
renforcer le vote de l'obligation enfin
ne sous-estimons pas l'impact
psychologique d'une obligation vaccinale
car dès lors que le vaccin est
obligatoire et non plus seulement
recommandé sa perception comme outil
efficace de santé publique en sort
renforcé et cela aussi c'est démontrer
alors mes chers collègues l'obligation
vaccinale est une politique d'aller vers
ne sont pas antinomiques tout au
contraire
l'obligation en plaçant l'état en
situation de devoir favorise cette allée
vers et encore une fois l'exemple le
plus récent celui de la nouvelle
calédonie l'illustrent les élus ont
adopté l'obligation vaccinale universel
le 3 septembre les communauté kanak
isolées ou en conséquence demandé à
l'état ou aux commissaires de leur
amener le vaccin en utilisant les
hélicoptères de l'armée et ce fut fait
depuis la part des personnes vaccinées
est passé de 31 à plus de 70% c'est
aussi pour cette raison que le président
du département le plus défavorisé de
métropole soutien et demande l'
obligation universelle
au fond cette proposition de loi porte
la conviction que la défense de
l'intérêt collectif et la plus efficace
pour protéger une société cette
conviction doit émaner de chacun de ses
membres oui mais elle doit aussi savoir
lorsque c'est nécessaire lorsque c'est
légitime être celle de la loi je mesure
dans ce débat sur l'obligation qu'ont
bien des années de progression d'invidu
et alice mme
on fini pour certains à une extrémité de
l'échiquier politique est vraiment
l'extrémité ont fini par transformer
ce bien si précieux que sont nos
libertés en individuel en un égoïsme
sociétal maquillée avec une parfaite
indécence en acte de résistance
oui c'est un choix politique que de
décider alors de l'arbitrage de ne pas
réserver les obligations à certains
soignants ou gendarmes et dans des dents
d'exonérer d'autres catégories de la
population
mes chers collègues la commission des
affaires sociales vous le savez a rejeté
ce texte que je vous invite à titre
personnel adopté en tout cas je pense
qu'il poursuit utilement un objectif que
nous partageons certainement rassembler
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens dans un
effort collectif pour vaincre cette
épidémie et tourner la page d'une crise
sanitaire qui n'a que trop duré je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
ah si
la présidente madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le sénateur patrick kanner
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices les
sénateurs sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour
examiner cette proposition de loi qui
vise donc à créer une obligation
vaccinale généralisée contre lacko vide
19 pour lutter structurellement contre
l'épidémie de comics 19 et sortir
progressivement de la crise sanitaire
que nous traversons la vaccination de
l'ensemble de la population est bien la
seule réponse efficace durable et sûre
compte tenu des limites et des risques
associés à la recherche d'une immunité
collective via la circulation du virus
la maîtrise de la quatrième vague
épidémique provoquée par l'apparition du
variant delta dès cet été sans recourir
à de nouvelles restrictions je le
rappelle montre d'ailleurs bien tout
l'intérêt de la vaccination
depuis le début de l'année 2021 le
gouvernement a lancé une campagne de
vaccination d'une ampleur sans précédent
selon un calendrier priorisant les
populations les plus fragiles puis
certaines catégories professionnelles et
enfin souvent à l'ensemble de la
population adulte est depuis la mi juin
aux mineurs âgés de 12 à 17 ans
aujourd'hui vous connaissez les chiffres
et ils sont satisfaisants
près de 51 millions de schémas vaccinaux
initiés et 44 millions de schémas
vaccinaux complet ce n'est là rien moins
que l'une des meilleures couvertures
vaccinales d'europe
si ces chiffres généraux sont
satisfaisants il ne faut évidemment pas
relâcher nos efforts et ce sous aucun
prétexte
ni pour vacciner ceux qui hésitent ou
doute encore car certains publics où
certains territoires notamment en
outre-mer reste insuffisamment couverts
ni non plus pour la campagne de rappel
sur laquelle j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir
face aux inégalités sociales et
territoriales dans l'accès à la
vaccination dont vous avez pu l'un et
l'autre évoqué des actions dit d'aller
vers ont été mises en place et ce dès le
printemps pour toucher les publics
précaires ou éloignés du soin plus de
90% des structures d'hébergement social
comme les foyers de travailleurs
migrants les centres d'accueil pour sans
abri ont été ciblés par au moins une
opération de vaccination
le principal point de progression
concerne aujourd'hui la vaccination des
personnes âgées de plus de 80 ans qui
reste inférieur à nos attentes
une instruction récente cosigné avec le
ministre de l'intérieur vise à mobiliser
l'ensemble des partenaires locaux et à
faciliter à la fois la prise de
rendez-vous et l'accès à la vaccination
à domicile des actions spécifiques
concernent également les outre-mer et
nous avons eu d'ailleurs l'occasion d'en
discuter ici même il ya quelques jours
la semaine dernière lors d'un débat
organisé par la délégation sénatoriale
et son président le sénateur harnes atom
heart and au pardon
par ailleurs nous progressons en matière
de rappel vaccinal un déclin de
l'efficacité vaccinale au cours du temps
a en effet était observé vous le savez
en particulier chez les personnes
fragiles face aux variants delta cette
perte d'efficacité s'observe du point de
vue de l'infection et de l'acompte et
une contagiosité mais aussi des formes
graves du coc vite 19 face à ce constat
et conformément aux avis rendu par la
haute autorité de santé et par le
conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale la france s'est engagée dès le
début du mois de septembre dans une
campagne de rappel à destination des
plus fragiles personnes de plus de 65
ans et personne comme morbide et
immunodéprimées six mois après leur
dernière dose de vaccin et personnes
vaccinées avec le vaccin johnsen quatre
semaines après leur primo vaccination
ainsi que plus récemment les
professionnels de santé et l'entourage
des personnes immunodéprimées
4,5 millions de personnes sont ainsi
déjà éligibles et compte tenu des
intervalles à respecter entre primo
vaccination et rappels et plus de 40%
d'entre elles ont déjà effectué leur
rappelle
la campagne de rappel vaccinal française
et l'une des plus dynamiques d'europe
même s'il convient de l'accélérer encore
évidemment la dose de rappel accroît la
protection individuelle contre les
formes graves mais également notre
protection collective
dans l'hypothèse où notre pays devrait
affronter au cours de l'hiver une
accélération brutale de la circulation
virale la stratégie vaccinale retenue
par le gouvernement a fait toutes ses
preuves en faisant appel à l'esprit de
responsabilité de nos concitoyens et en
mobilisant toutes les énergies
disponibles à ce titre il faut saluer la
contribution de toutes les parties
prenantes notamment les collectivités
territoriales les élus locaux à la
conduite de cette campagne avec le
soutien opérationnel humain et financier
de l'état et en particulier des agences
régionales de santé
nous avons souhaité mesdames et
messieurs les les sénatrices et les
sénateurs un équilibre entre protection
de la santé publique et libertés
individuelles en n'imposant pas de
manière généralisée la vaccination à nos
concitoyens il faut continuer en
poursuivant les opérations d'aller vers
en les affinant plus encore vers les
publics les plus éloignés du système de
soins et poursuivre la campagne de
rappel dont le public éligible va lui
aussi progressivement ses larges aires
mais ce n'est pas en imposant une
obligation générale
inapplicable et qui pourrait même créer
nous le pensons a certain nombre
d'injustices
que nous parviendrons à la complétude de
la couverture vaccinale seuls les
professionnels se sont vu imposer une
telle obligation vous le savez afin
d'être protégé de protéger les patients
ont ils prennent soin nous croyons en
effet à l'information à la pédagogie à
l'incitation à l'accompagnement rappelle
les gestes barrière à la nécessité
effectivement monsieur le sénateur
d'effectuer les contrôles des passes à
nanterre de ne pas baisser la garde mais
nous ne croyons pas à l'obligation
vaccinale pour progressiez sur le chemin
de la vaccination collective il faut
convaincre et non forcé c'est ainsi que
nous avons avancé depuis le début avec
des résultats remarquables grâce à
l'implication de tous et c'est ainsi que
nous entendons poursuivre c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous l'avez compris
le gouvernement ne soutiendra pas la
présente proposition de loi je vous
remercie
merci dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à madame
véronique guillotin pour cinq minutes et
pour le pop rdse
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur madame
la présidente de commission chers
collègues l'examen de cette proposition
de loi de nos collègues socialistes a
semble-t-il ravivé la flamme du combat
des antilles vaccinant contente crier au
scandale voire au génocide planétaire et
d'appeler à la révolte contre je cite
cette nouvelle arme biologique
pour avoir reçu un grand nombre de
sollicitations de cette teneur je
soutiens les auteurs et rapporteur de la
proposition de loi qui ont dû faire face
à une campagne massive d'intimidation
au-delà du débat de fond auquel je vais
me prêter n'est pas acceptable de voir
ainsi menacer les élus de la république
le pouvoir législatif doit pouvoir
continuer à s'exercer à être force de
proposition quel que soit le sujet et
quelles que soient les crispations au
sein de notre société
j'aimerais avant tout rappeler une
nouvelle fois combien je suis favorable
à la vaccination
elle est la seule manière de prévenir et
contenir les maladies infectieuses
graves elle est notre seule porte de
sortie dans cette crise elle est une
chance formidable alors que la pandémie
nous entraîner inexorablement vers un
abîme sanitaire économique social et
nous l'avons vu hier éthiques la baisse
du nombre d'hospitalisations et de décès
par le d'elle-même un cycle différentiel
entre les départements et les pays où le
taux de vaccination est élevé et ceux où
il reste faible le vaccin protège même
avec les variants des formes graves et
sévères de côte de l'aco vide il réduit
aussi la charge virale en cas
d'infection puisque les personnes
vaccinées en fait qd 12 fois moins que
les autres une grande étude française
réalisée sur 22 millions de personnes et
publié cette semaine confirment
d'ailleurs cette efficacité les
personnes vaccinées de plus de 50 ans
ont neuf fois moins de risques d'être
hospitalisées et d'en mourir
s'agissant de l'obligation vaccinale
elle ne me choque pas dans l'absolu la
première date de 1902 avec la variole et
nous en sommes aujourd'hui à 11 vaccin
obligatoire pour les enfants j'ai
souvenu cette réforme en 2018 convaincu
qu'il fallait frapper fort dans un
contexte de défiance croissante à
l'égard des vaccins d'un recul de la
couverture vaccinale et de résurgence
inquiétante de certaines maladies que
l'on croyait d'un autre temps
face à la coved comme l'a souligné très
justement l'académie de médecine la
vaccination
pas seulement un geste civique c'est un
impératif éthique car les conséquences
sur la santé la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens sont quasiment sans
précédent néanmoins j'ai le sentiment
que cette obligation arrive au mauvais
mauvais moment elle arrive trop tôt non
pas parce que le vaccin ne soit pas
fiable trouvait trop précocément mais
face à un virus encore mal connue et
évolutif nous ne maîtrisons ni le schéma
vaccinal ni le nombre de doses qui
seront nécessaires et la fréquence
d'injection les variants obligeront
probablement adaptée le vaccin et nous
n'avons encore que peu de visibilité sur
l'évolution de cette maladie à moyen
terme en cela le coc vide est bien
différent des maladies ciblées dans
l'es11 vaccins déjà obligatoire mais
d'une certaine manière l'obligation
vaccinale arriverait également trop tard
85 % du public cible les plus de 12 ans
sont déjà vaccinés les 12 17 ans des
taux de vaccinations encourageant alors
que leur dose leur sont ouvertes depuis
le 15 juin seulement et surtout que le
pass sanitaires leur est imposée depuis
le 30 septembre seulement la dynamique
est là elle est positive elle est
probablement renforcés par la phase sera
probablement renforcés par la fin de
gratuité des tests dans quelques jours
malgré le bruit qu'ils font les anti
vaccin anti passes sont largement
minoritaires enfin tous les indicateurs
sont au vert et nous devons en prendre
conscience les ans l'incidence la
circulation virale les hospitalisations
tant bien même nous devons continuer à
faire attention aussi proposer la
vaccination obligatoire maintenant
relancerait un débat qui semble
aujourd'hui datée puisque l'immense
majorité de la population est désormais
vaccinés pour les plus récalcitrants
l'instauration d'une obligation
notamment assorti d'une sanction
raviverait les crispations au moment où
la résilience envers le vaccin est une
forme de confiance semble s'instaurer au
moment où la société se tourne vers son
avenir et les contours d'une relance qui
se doit d'être historique
d'autre part elle ne permettrait pas
toucher ceux qui souhaiteraient être
vaccinés mais en font très trop éloignés
ceux qui vivent en zones très rurales
qui ont des difficultés pour se déplacer
ou simplement pour prendre et vous je
pense par exemple aux plus de 80 ans qui
ne sont pas un établissement et chez qui
le taux de vaccination est encore
insuffisant enfin même si la propre la
proposition de loi demeure vague à ce
sujet cette obligation vaccinale
reviendrait à remplacer l'autre passe
sanitaire par l'impasse vaccinale sinon
comment effectuer les contrôles dans la
population générale dans le cas d'une
obligation pour tous devra-t-on
interdire l'école aux enfants non
vaccinés ces questions restent en
suspens alors qu'elle me semble encore
primordiale tout pour toutes ces raisons
le groupe rds votera contre cette
proposition de loi ne songeons pas notre
fusil d'épaulé
aujourd'hui je le répète nous sommes
favorables à la vaccination la plus
large possible et invitons les français
à s'engager sur cette voie pour leur
santé et celle des autres le pass
vaccinale qui s'est montrée mines amant
efficace avec un meilleur tour de
couverture européen en termes de
vaccination nous semble pour l'heure
suffisant en ce qu'il permet de
préserver des activités avec un certain
degré de protection et de liberté
pourrait pleinement efficient et doivent
néanmoins nous répétons s'assortir de
mesures plus fortes en matière de
sensibilisation et de pédagogie et pour
les personnes les plus éloignées de la
vaccination une campagne massive doit
s'engager avec les collectivités locales
au plus près des territoires je vous
remercie merci la parole et à monsieur
stéphane ravier non-inscrits pour 3
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues décidément
l'elysée et matignon ça pouvoir compter
sur les idiots utiles en toutes
circonstances preuve en est aujourd'hui
même aujourd'hui encore tandis que le
gouvernement présente la prorogation du
pass sanitaire au conseil des ministres
les sénateurs socialistes jamais en
retard d'une loi liberticide veulent
imposer l'obligation vaccinale au
français y compris aux mineurs le tout
assorti bien évidemment d'une amende en
cas de non respect de cette infamie
le pass sanitaire a pourtant déjà
fracturé notre pays entre ceux dont la
profession est obligé trop vacciner ceux
qui se sont résignés à être vaccinés
pour vivre sans être pourchassés ceux
qui ont été vaccinés volontairement et
ce dont je suis qui ne sont pas vaccinés
qui ne veulent pas l'être et qui pour en
avoir marre d'être harcelée seraient
tentés désormais plutôt que de faire un
discours de trois minutes de vous
adresser pour seule réponse les cinq la
tracy chez ans cameron mais la
bienséance sénatoriales n'en retiendra
de le faire cette fois encore après
dix-huit mois de mensonges
d'impréparation de manipulation de
culpabilisation le pouvoir est arrivé à
ses fins chaque citoyen est devenu aux
yeux de l'autre fric juge ou un criminel
en puissance ce désastre ne vous
suffit-il pas que vous faut que vous
vouliez encore jeté de l'huile sur le
feu de la division la loi scélérate
dresser les français les uns contre les
autres alors que sa raison d'être et la
réalisation du bien commun et de l'unité
nationale à l'instar des pays
autoritaires du tadjikistan et du
turkménistan qui sont les deux seuls
pays à avoir imposé le vaccin à tous les
adultes la france devient le maquereau
nice temps où la liberté de conscience
de ses habitants est écrasé par
l'argument de sécurité sanitaire au
contraire bien je le dis depuis de longs
mois il n'y a une ligne qui est un arbre
mes chers collègues il nous faut
l'ériger en principe de liberté
indépassable le vaccin doit toujours
rester vont enterrer jamais obligatoire
vous disposez à ces deux supports de
propagande et de support estampillé
journalistes pour tenter de convaincre
plutôt que de contraindre fait été pour
justifier le passé ni terre vous
annonciez le charge virale mille fois
supérieur du variant delta mille fois
rien de tout cela n'a été observée dans
la réalité alors que plus de la moitié
des français n'était pas encore vaccinée
vous vous êtes trompés au plus tôt vous
avez délibérément voulu tromper voulu
faire peur une fois de plus
en définitive le dispositif législatif
que vous nous présentez et gravement
attentatoires aux libertés fondamentales
et a dû verser rites et des droits sur
les plan philosophique et conjoncturels
tous se posent à continuer cette fuite
en avant autoritaire initié par le
pouvoir en place c'est pourquoi mes
chers collègues je fais appel à votre
esprit critique pour voter en faveur des
libertés et contre l'obligation
vaccinale qui accélérerait à n'en pas
douter le basculement de notre société
dans un quotidien de surveillance et de
contrôle généralisé
merci la parole est maintenant madame
corinne féret pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
et pour 9 minutes sous
moi madame la sénatrice avant que vous
ne commenciez votre intervention je vais
rappeler les règles combres concernant
le port du masque dans l'hémicycle le
masque n'est plus obligatoire à la
tribune voilà donc chaque sénateur et
des houes sénatrice est libre de faire
comme il le souhaite lorsqu'il est en
tribunes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je n'avais pas prévu de
dire les quelques mots que je vais dire
à l'instant mais ce que je viens
d'entendre pour moi totalement
inacceptable je ne peux me sur aviez
accepté et entendre vos insultes vous
n'avez pas le droit parce que vous êtes
parlementaire de nous parler sur ce ton
de nous traiter d'idiot vous parlez de
loisirs et la
relaxe et je voulais le dire vous n'avez
plus à paroles messieurs ravier c'est
moi qui suis au micro donc ça suffit
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes donc réunis pour débattre de
la proposition de loi des sénateurs et
sénatrices du groupe socialistes
écologistes et républicains tendant à
instaurer une vaccination obligatoire
contre le strass cov 2 il apparaît en
effet légitime à ce stade de nous
interroger de questionner les politiques
publiques visant à faire face à la crise
sanitaire et ce faisant d'échanger sur
ce sujet de l'obligation vaccinale avec
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale
en associant vaccination et
conditionnement de la vie sociale à la
présentation d'un pass sanitaires
le gouvernement a mis en place une
obligation de vaccination à direct qui
ne dit pas son nom nous ne voulons pas
non plus que l'obligation vaccinale est
la luttre lutte contre la pandémie
repose sur quelques professions sûr et
efficace
la vaccination contre la copie de 19 est
aujourd'hui le seul moyen d'atteindre
une protection collective suffisante
pour espérer maîtriser durablement
l'épidémie et permettre un retour à une
vie normale en limitant les formes
graves les hospitalisations mais aussi
en réduisant la transmissibilité du
virus la vaccination est la clé à la
fois d'une sortie de crise et de notre
liberté collective
s'il annonce à la mi juillet par le
président de la république de
l'extension du pass sanitaire a permis
de relancer le rythme de vaccination
on voit bien que cet outil a épuisé ses
et chez les primo vacciner vaccination
ne progresse pas suffisamment on observe
même une tendance à la baisse depuis fin
juillet les personnes les plus
vulnérables ne sont pas suffisamment
vacciner 83 % des plus de 80 ans
seulement sont vaccinés contre 100 % en
espagne et uniquement 85% de nos
concitoyens avec commandité c'est trop
peu de même la vaccination est très
inégale selon les territoires
les français vivant dans les
départements ultramarins sont
insuffisamment vaccinées à ce jour on
dit déplore un nombre d'admissions en
réanimation et de décès sans précédent
la fracture territoriale est réel fin
septembre la seine-saint-denis affichée
elle aussi un taux de vaccination très
en dessous de la moyenne nationale
se sont tristement dans les départements
les plus pauvres que la population est
la moins vacciner en somme il reste
environ neuf millions de français
vaccinés à ce rythme ils ne le seront
pas d'ici l'été 2022 or le risque d'une
cinquième vague cet hiver n'est pas
écartée par les ip épidémiologistes
non nous ne sommes pas sortis de la
pandémie le vainqueur delta représente
toujours un risque élevé capable de
mettre une fois de plus notre système de
soins en difficulté il faut donc au plus
vite agir pour gagner les quelques
points de vaccination qui nous manque
nous considérons qu'il est nécessaire
d'aller vers les français non encore
vaccinés en particulier les plus
fragiles
la vaccination obligatoire en population
générale créera une obligation envers
les temps de déployer des moyens en
matière de pédagogie et d'incitation à
la vaccination ces derniers seront très
utiles pour protéger ceux qui ont des
difficultés d'accès aux soins et à
l'information ou ceux qui sont dans la
défiance
certaines politiques publiques
particulièrement le pass sanitaire
souffre aujourd'hui d'un manque de
lisibilité ces derniers divise les
français et limite leur liberté
individuelle à travers des règles
souvent peu cohérente
incompréhensibles ou peu compréhensible
par tous avec la vaccination obligatoire
al'inverse de se passe nous faisons le
choix de la clarté et surtout de la
responsabilité nous espérons notamment
mettre fin aux trop nombreuses
déprogrammation auxquels nos hôpitaux
sont encore aujourd'hui contraints elles
ont des conséquences sanitaires
considérables avec notamment des retards
en matière de prévention
l'obligation vaccinale doit permettre à
l'hôpital public de reprendre l'ensemble
de ses activités au bénéfice de tous les
patients notre proposition de loi qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre légal existant
de santé publique se veut souple nous
souhaitons que les personnes de plus de
60 en plus vulnérable et susceptible
d'être hospitalisés soit concerné en
priorité
l'obligation doit s'appliquer de façon
pragmatique et intelligente il s'agira
d'étendre progressivement le dispositif
par tranches d'âge ou comme cela a été
dit de l'interrompre rapidement selon
l'évolution de conséquence nos
connaissances médicales en particulier
je pense les nouvelles thérapies qui
serait tout à fait efficace certains
nous interpelle sur la légalité de notre
proposition le conseil d'état a déjà eu
l'occasion de juger que lorsque la santé
publique l'exigent
l'obligation vaccinale est une
restriction proportionnée aux droits de
l'intégrisme l'intégrité physique quant
à la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme elle a en avril dernier admis
que si l'obligation vaccinale
représentait une ingérence dans le
principe du droit au respect de la vie
privée celle ci était proportionnée au
regard du principe de la solidarité
sociale et aux buts que sur la
protection d'un santé et la protection
des droits d'autrui
du fait de l'ampleur des conséquences de
la colline 19 sur la société en matière
de santé de restriction des libertés
fondamentales telles que la liberté
d'aller et venir de vie économique et
sociale nous sommes légitimement fondé à
penser qu'il n'existe pas d'obstacle
juridique à reconnaître l'obligation
vaccinale contre la copie 19 comme une
solution proportionnée quand la liberté
individuelle elle porte une atteinte à
la santé collective de la population
l'equilibre doit être rétablie par la
loi afin de protéger l'ensemble de la
société rappelle que la nouvelle
calédonie mais cette obligation
vaccinale en oeuvre depuis le début du
mois de septembre elle voit son taux de
vaccination augmenté rapidement depuis
cette date et les choses vont dans le
bon sens tout comme le passage de 3 à 11
vaccin obligatoire chez les enfants
votez en 2018 cela nous a permis
d'atteindre les objectifs fixés après de
longues années de stagnation nous ne
proposons proposant rien d'original
udine dit certain de qualifie parfois
d'irresponsables on oublié en obligeant
les français à se faire injecter un
vaccin qui sinon seraient entre
guillemets expérimental je rappelle
aussi que pour être commercialisé à
vaccin doit obtenir une autorisation de
mise sur le marché les vaccins contre la
copie 19 ont été développés en un temps
record certes mais ils sont ils ont
satisfait bien évidemment aux
différentes phases des six cliniques
habituellement exigé et obtenu donc
cette autorisation ce ne sont donc pas
des vaccins expérimentaux nous suivons
les recommandations des pouvoirs publics
mes chers collègues agir pour assurer la
sécurité des français et protéger notre
système de santé le personnel soignant
voilà ce que nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui
ça va en modifier la stratégie vaccinale
de notre pays et pour ce faire ces
outils c'est tout simplement s'adapter à
la réalité de l'évolution de la pandémie
pour les sources pour les sénateurs et
sénatrices du groupe socialistes
écologistes et républicains vous l'avez
compris l'heure de la vaccination de
l'obligation vaccinale est venu pardon
elle seule constitue une démarche de
protection collective de lutte contre
les inégalités territoriales les
inégalités sociales en créant un devoir
de l'état d'aller vers ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui éloigné de la protection que
constitue la vaccination je vous
remercie
la parole est à monsieur martin lévriers
pour six minutes et pour nos groupes r&d
pays
monsieur le président pardon madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues
tout est ici question d'arbitrage et de
choix politiques quelle liberté sommes
nous prêts à sacrifier pour être mieux
protégés
quel danger sommes nous prêts à côtoyer
pour garder le maximum de liberté
chacun possède ses valeurs propres sa
représentation du monde qui l'amène à
choisir un point équilibre entre liberté
et sécurité
et c'est le rôle même du législateur de
construire ce point d'équilibré qui fait
nation
considérant la vaccination obligatoire
comme étant le seul chemin pour sortir
d'une politique de sécurité sanitaire
est entré dans une politique de santé
publique patrick kanner bernard jomier
marie pierre de la gontrie monique lubin
et plusieurs de leurs collègues ont
déposé au sénat un texte qui dans un
article unique propose de modifier
l'article l trente et un 11-2 du code de
santé publique afin d'ajouter la
vaccination contre le strass co2 dans la
liste des vaccinations obligatoires si
nous comprenez l'objectif car la
vaccination est notre meilleur atout
notons que nous ne pensons pas qu'elles
que cette démarche soit nécessaire
l'intérêt public de la vaccination est
indéniable à date et depuis le début de
la campagne de vaccination en france 59
51 millions de personnes ont reçu au
moins une injection et plus de 49
millions ont désormais un schéma
vaccinal complet aussi compte tenu de
l'ampleur de notre couverture vaccinale
la pédagogie et la prospection des
territoires en carence reste les
approches les plus utiles à destination
de concitoyens non vaccinés souvenez
vous il ya moins d'un an le 3 décembre
2020 une enquête ifop fiducial menée
auprès de 1003 personnes indiqué que
seuls 39% des français avaient
l'intention de se faire vacciner
les doutes quant à l'efficacité du
vaccin et la crainte d'éventuels effets
secondaires après sa mise au point
rapide la perte de confiance dans les
scientifiques la montée de l'individu
l'isthme et l'hostilité aux institutions
expliqué en grande partie ses réticences
à titre de comparaison les allemands à
la même époque qu'ils étaient prêts à
79% les britanniques à 69% les italiens
à 65 % le taux se situe à 60 4% aux
etats-unis les plus favorables à thaksin
station étant les indiens et les chinois
avec des taux de 87 et 85 % en france
les incitations à la vaccination liés à
la mise en place du pass sanitaire qui
préserve une liberté de choix pour ceux
qui désireraient encore réfléchir ont
largement fait preuve
d'ailleurs il est à noter que du respect
du confinement aux gestes barrière en
passant par la vaccination les français
ont joué le jeu et ce depuis les
prémices de la pandémie et nous devons
ici les remercier nous avons eu raison
de faire confiance à l'esprit de
responsabilité de chacun c'est la raison
pour laquelle la vaccination tente
aujourd'hui vers une couverture totale
dans un climat qui s'apaise voir est
totalement apaisé la fin de la gratuité
généralisée des tests de dépistage à la
mi octobre devrait elle aussi renforcer
les incitations à la vaccination et il
en va de même pour les dispositifs
d'aller vers j'en avais exprimé la
demande lors de la déclaration du
gouvernement sur la place de la
stratégie vaccinale dans le dispositif
de lutte contre l'épidémie du 17
décembre dernier les dispositifs d'aller
vers développé très tôt pendant la
campagne de vaccination se poursuivre
pour permettre la vaccination des
personnes éloignées du système de soins
les personnes victimes de la fracture
numérique nous pouvons prendre
rendez-vous en ligne ou encore les
personnes en situation de handicap les
travailleurs migrants les détenus etc
des rats un premier bilan fait état de
1,2 million de patients vaccinés grâce à
ce dispositif d'aller vers et d'autres
opérations sont en cours de montée en
charge
à la demande pertinentes du conseil de
l'ordre des médecins généralistes et
avec la pluie du gouvernement le 7
juillet à cannes il a validé l'envoi au
médecin traitant de la liste de leurs
patients non vaccinés un point sur
lequel nous comptions fortement pour
accentuer ses efforts visant à informer
et convaincre les personnes n'ayant reçu
encore aucune dose je profite d'ailleurs
de ce temps de parole pour les
encourager à continuer de contribuer au
succès de cette mesure peut-être la plus
importante de toutes
aussi alors que la situation sanitaire
s'améliore et que certaines personnes
vaccinées semble réticente à une
troisième dose parce que suffisamment
rassuré à leur sens par les chiffres de
la pandémie la proposition de loi du
groupe socialiste aura un effet
totalement contre-productif et braquera
davantage les plus réfractaires si la
pédagogie génère la confiance la
coercition elle rajoute de la peur à la
peur en outre le texte que nous
examinons aujourd'hui reste muet sur la
mentalité de cette obligation vaccinale
les conséquences sont aux sanctions en
cas de manquement et laisse derrière et
récente hier par dont la question des
moyens de contrôle de son respect dénuée
de toute sanction cette mesure
obligatoire et dépourvue de tout effet
crédible une bonne loi dois je le
rappeler est d'abord une loi applicable
c'est à dire normative enfin et pour
conclure le gouvernement et la majorité
présidentielle soucieux déterminer le
point d'équilibré entre liberté et
sécurité se voyait souvenez vous
reprocher leurs abus de pouvoir leur
autoritarisme leur autoritarisme parmi
leurs détracteurs ceux là même qui
reprenait le 100% pédagogie revendique
aujourd'hui le 100% coercition en résumé
vous vouliez la liberté désormais vous
prônez la sécurité absolue vous n'avez
pas compris que le pass sanitaires et la
concrétisation du en même temps il
construit le juste équilibre qui permet
à chaque français d'être acteur de la
gestion de cette pandémie vous vous
comprendrez que pour toutes ces raisons
notre groupe votera contre cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur daniel
chassaing pour l'europe les indépendants
et pour cinq minutes
même la présidente monsieur le ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
monsieur leur apportant mes chers
collègues la découverte des vaccins
contre kobe de 19 en un temps record a
été une première grande victoire en
particulier pour les vaccins arn
messager qui ouvre de nouveaux horizons
thérapeutique la vaccination massive de
la population française a permis de
stabiliser la situation sanitaire où en
serions nous sans vaccin 21 nouveaux
départements sont passés sous le seuil
de da l'herbe ce lundi
si bien que de nombreux enfants peuvent
désormais avoir une scolarité sans
masque je souhaite remercier les élus
les soignants les sapeurs pompiers des
départements qui ont fait un travail
considérable aux côtés de l'état pour
mener à bien la campagne de vaccination
à partir de cette semaine des tests de
confort ne seront plus remboursés par la
sécurité sociale notamment les campagnes
de rappel pour les personnes
immunodéprimées des sous les soignants
et les personnes âgées depuis 35 ans
actuellement plus de 87% de la
population éligible a reçu une première
dose de vaccin en métropole des médecins
généralistes sont en première ligne pour
poursuivre l'effort maximal avec
désormais la possibilité de disposer de
vaccins pfizer et moderna le pass
sanitaire a permis de franchir un cap
difficile sans imposer une vaccination
obligatoire pour tous ce dispositif
incitatif a fait ses preuves assurant la
sécurité collective le gouvernement se
pose la question de son assouplissement
et à terme sa suppression de nombreuses
incertitudes demeurent malgré tout
premier rang duquel figurent la
possibilité émergentes de nouveaux
variants résistant au bac simple mais
depuis des mois les autorités
scientifiques et médicales s'accordent à
dire
que le vaccin représente le meilleur
moyen d'endiguer les veilles de
contamination la vaccination sauf de
nombreuses vies comme le confirme des
études de l'année c'est mou l'acclament
publié ce lundi les personnes vaccinées
de 50 ans et plus en neuf fois moins de
risques d'être hospitalisées ou de
mourir ducobu de 19 que les non vaccinés
c'est un fait
des patients hospitalisés sont
majoritairement des personnes non
vaccinées nous le constatons gt nous
avons été nombreux à éprouver la
tentation de l'obligation vaccinale le
groupe les indépendants
avaient approuvé l'obligation vaccinale
en direction du personnel soignant et
d'un certain nombre de professionnels
particulièrement explorer la question
d'une vaccination obligatoire aurait pu
effectivement supposée comme nous
l'indiquent bernard jomier et le groupe
socialiste dans la proposition de loi
pour autant il nous semble qu imposer
une obligation universelle à ce ce thème
ne nous semble pas nécessaire les 9
millions de français éligibles qui ne
sont pas vaccinés forment un ensemble
très hétérogène alors que la vaccination
progresse ces jeunes 15 % des plus de 80
ans ne sont toujours pas vaccinées la
participation des médecins généralistes
et l'envoi de courriers d'invitation à
la vaccination devrait permettre de
combler ce retard chez les personnes les
plus vulnérables
nous considérons donc que les données
actuelles favorables ne justifie plus
l'instauration d'une obligation
vaccinale obligatoire le pass sanitaire
représentent une solution de compromis
qui a donc bien fonctionné nous aspirons
tous à sortir de la crise sanitaire le
plus rapidement possible il nous semble
cependant que cela doit se faire dans un
esprit de concorde l'exemple de
l'espagne montre qu'il est possible de
lever les dernières résistances à la
vaccination par la responsabilisation le
dialogue et l'incitation
l'évolution positive de notre situation
sanitaire en france ne semble pas donc
pour l'instant justifier la mise en
place d'une faction oublier tout une
vaccination obligatoire contre la copie
19 noms trop gros ne votera pas contre 2
ne votera pas pour cette proposition de
loi certains s'abstiendront d'autres
autres ont compris merci
si la parole est à monsieur alain milon
pour le groupe est républicain pour sept
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur
sur l'auteur composition doit les
questions simples sont souvent celles
dont les réponses sont les plus
complexes la ppl que nous examinons
aujourd'hui en est l'illustration
probante un texte simple composant
uniquement de complété par un alinéa
supplémentaires un article qui en compte
déjà 11 l'a priori un ajout anodin qui
s'inscrit dans la lignée de cet article
31 11-2 du code de la santé publique qui
liste les vaccins obligatoires la ppl
examiné propose donc d'instaurer la
vaccination obligatoire contre sarko f2
pour tous sauf contre indication
médicale
vaccination qui ne seraient pas pris en
charge par la sécurité sociale un titre
personnel je suis en général un ardent
défenseur de la vaccination obligatoire
mais être convaincu sur le principe ne
suffit pas permettez moi de citer ici
claude bernard pour qui à la source de
toute connaissance il y a id une pensée
puis l'expérience vient confirmer l'idée
si on applique cette démarche à l'examen
de cette ppl il nous appartient de
confronter l'idée de cette vaccination
obligatoire à l'environnement juridique
et scientifique ont regard notamment de
l'état des connaissances et des
techniques la question inclus dans cette
ppl implique de déterminer si la
protection individuelle et collective de
santé justifie de rendre obligatoire
cette vaccination contre sackhoff de
dans la résolution
23,61 adopté en janvier dernier par
l'assemblée parlementaire du conseil de
l'europe celui ci a invité les états à
je cite s'assurer que les citoyens et
citoyennes sont informés que la
vaccination n'est pas obligatoire et que
personne ne subit deux pressions
politiques sociales ou autres pour se
faire vacciner et en ce qui concerne les
enfants je cite à nouveau de veiller à
un juste équilibre entre le déploiement
rapide vaccination chez les enfants et
les âmes à justifier des préoccupations
concernant la sécurité et l'efficacité
des vaccins au sein de notre assemblée
nous avons voté je vais voter avec vous
en faveur du principe d'une obligation
vaccinale pour certains personnels visés
par la loi relative à la gestion de la
crise sanitaire publié le 5 août 2021 à
savoir le personnel soignant les
personnels accompagnant les personnes
vulnérables dans les établissements
médico-sociaux la stratégie déployée
depuis le mois de décembre a consisté à
prioriser les personnes les plus
vulnérables qui étaient susceptibles de
développer des maladies aggravantes
cette stratégie évolutive par rapport
aux tranches d'âge étaient nécessaires
pour éviter l'engorgement des hôpitaux
mais également pour faire face à un
manque de doses si dès le début d'année
2004 il avait fallu vacciner une large
majorité de la population
depuis cet été une incitation la
vaccination plus forte avec la mise en
place du pass sanitaire produit ses
effets dans le pays 50 millions de
français sont vaccinés et je m'en
réjouis toutefois dès l'examen du projet
de loi sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire j'avais alerté souvenez vous
en sur les mutations de ce savent cov 2
avec l'apparition de nouveaux variants
qui pour l'instant je dis bien pour
l'instant n'échappe pas encore à la
vaccination
mais sommes-nous sûrs que dans les mois
à venir nous n'aurons pas un variant qui
échappera à cette vaccination dans ce
cas nous serons obligés de prévoir tous
les ans une vaccination obligatoire
contre les variantes du sarc of 2 dans
ces conditions il semble plus judicieux
et acceptable par nos concitoyens
d'aligner la vaccination contre savent
comme deux sur le modèle de la
vaccination contre la grippe qui n'est
pas obligatoire mais fortement
conseillée pour les personnes
vulnérables
méfions-nous se savent comme de est en
train de muter ne sommes pas sûrs de la
pérennité de l'efficacité de la
vaccination actuelle ne parlons ton pas
actuellement déjà d'une troisième dante
bernard jomier a insisté sur le fait
qu'il y avait déjà pas mal de vaccins
qui était mis en place avec un énorme
succès je voudrais juste a ajouté que
ces vaccins qui marche très bien qu'ils
ont protégé les populations qui ont
entraîné l'émission complète de
certaines maladies sont des vaches à ou
contre des maladies bactériennes je n'ai
pas toutes les citer tuberculose par
exemple ou contre des maladies virales
mais des maladies virales avec un virus
non variant ici on n'a pas le cas les
auteurs de cette ppl prose propose aussi
que cette vaccination ne soient plus
prises en charge par la sécurité sociale
donc plus gratuite comme c'est le cas
actuellement même s'il s'agit de
contourner l'article 40 permettez moi
juste d'ajouter que j'aurais aimé qu'un
remboursement par les complémentaires
santé puisse être envisagée enfin cette
ppl
qui prétend imposer une humiliation ne
prévoit aucune condition pour rendre
cette obligation effective à l'égard des
plus réfractaires ni de sanction en cas
de non respect de ladite obligations il
y a certes une obligation dans l'article
1 31 11-2 mais c'est une obligation qui
concerne les enfants pour la crèche pour
les écoles la vaccination quand on sait
que deux c'est à partir de 12 ans donc
il n'y a aucune sanction de prévu dans
ce texte et c'est peut-être que je là
aussi quelque part gênant c'est au ppl
ne prévoit donc ne revêt donc une
dimension exclusivement proclame à
thouars écrire dans un article de loi
que la vaccination est obligatoire n'a
strictement aucun effet sur la
généralisation de cette vaccination au
jus de ces différents éléments le groupe
ait l'air dans son ensemble votre rat
contre ce texte
merci
la parole est à madame français mangent
pour le groupe écologiste ayant été
territoire et pour cinq minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mais siècle sa collègue depuis
l'instauration du pass sanitaires la
vaccination a cessé de relever seulement
d'un choix individuel tout en maintenant
le principe éthique du consentement puis
avec la fin du remboursement des tests
qui fragilisera certainement la
stratégie du tester alerte et protéger
la question de la vaccination
obligatoire cheminait nous y sommes nous
poursuivons le même objectif de
l'immunité collective que cette ppl et
les données sont 106 équivoque la
vaccination protège des formes graves de
la maladie et contribue à maintenir
notre système de soins à moindre tension
d'autant que la pandémie l'a percutée
alors qu'il traversait une crise
profonde très vite la vaccination a été
l'alpha et l'oméga de la politique
publique de santé qui s'est heurtée à
l'état des inégalités sociales et
territoriales et à la crise de confiance
dans la parole politique et
institutionnelle une des plus grandes
études à ce jour sur la défiance
vaccinale avec un échantillon de 135
mille personnes montraient qu'elles
concernent majoritairement des personnes
peu diplômés faisant partie des 10% les
plus pauvres cette population vit
marginalisation et une relégation
sociale qui nourrit un manque de
confiance envers les institutions
entraînant cette défiance envers la
parole la politique vaccinale a
contrario c'est dans les pays où la
confiance envers les autorités publiques
est forte que l'on observe le plus haut
taux d'adhésion à la vaccination il
faudrait revenir sur les obstacles les
inégalités d'accès aux soins les déserts
médicaux la réalité de l'isolément d'une
partie sensible de la population qui ont
conduit les collectivités territoriales
et les services déconcentrés la santé à
mettre l'accent sur la démarche de là
les verts aujourd'hui plus de 80% de la
population éligible soit des plus de 12
ans est complètement vaccinés
l'hypothèse serait qu'il nous faudrait
avec la vaccination obligatoire gagner
avant la possible vague hivernale les
quelques pour cent pour atteindre une
situation estimé stable d'un bruit
endémique de fausses sans gravité ce
raisonnement transpose l'expérience des
vaccinations obligatoires passé
notamment des enfants ou une vaccination
protégeait des décennies entières alors
que l'on parle déjà de troisième dose
tout ce que la protection apportée par
la vaccination décroît avec le temps
notamment pour les plus âgés
la teinte de la couverture vaccinale
totale et durable est un objectif qui se
dérobe avec le temps sans même parler
des variants qui ne manqueront pas
d'apparaître quand 75% des vaccins
administrés sont concentrés dans les 10
pays les plus riches alors que la
pandémie est mondiale il est probable
qu'il faille renouveler ça l'a été dit
ça a été dit régulièrement voir tous les
ans le geste vaccinal la priorité nous
sommes plutôt la couverture vaccinale
complète est suivi dans le temps des
populations à risque élevé et donc est
donc une action résolue pour comprendre
le retard français dans la vaccination
des plus de 80 ans notamment
92% et demie nord les soins des 65-74
ans présente à schéma vaccinal complet
mais près de 15 % de non vaccinés chez
les plus de 80 ans populations isolées
populations précaires admissibles qui
apportera de plus l'obligation at-on
vraiment tout fait quant à la politique
de la les verts c'est vraiment se donner
un étonnant satisfecit alors que
plusieurs pays européens dont l'espagne
ont quasi 100% de vacciner dans cette
tranche d'âge sans aucune obligation
pas de solution magique ou paresseuse il
nous faut comprendre puis consentir
l'effort pour mettre en place les
mesures correctives canton copulation
rétive à la vaccination par défiance
plusieurs acteurs le samu notamment
souligner qu'en prenant le temps dans
une rencontre de proximité peu
maintiennent refus là encore ce défaut
de confiance ou d'information ne sera
pas résolue par une injonction
institutionnels supplémentaire au
contraire l'obligation visqueux d'être
contre-productive et de figer la
résistance quant aux sanctions
financières voire aux interdictions de
travail et qui pourraient en résulter
la société en sortira encore plus de
nouveaux plutôt fracturé voire plus
inégalitaire en poussant les plus
précaires comme toute obligation des
mesures de contrôle et de surveillance
en découleront la france s'engagerait à
leurs seuls dans cette voie réactivant
une conception verticale
centralisée de la gestion de la pandémie
enfin comme le rappelle l'institut
pasteur la vaccination obligatoire ne
permettra même si elle était totale même
si la vaccination de était
totale toute la population générale ne
permettra ni un retour plus rapide à la
vie quotidienne ni même d'en finir avec
le pass sanitaires et les esb arrière
dire autre chose et au pire un mensonge
c'est une inexactitude et progrès la
vaccination obligatoire pendant aurait
le contre-pied de la position de l'om
est-ce convainquent plus tôt que
contrainte et le virus étant là pour
longtemps la vaccination obligatoire
pour épais permettent d'aller peut-être
plus vite à court terme et avec
l'adhésion de la société on ira plus
loin nos groupes écologistes remercie le
groupe socialiste d'avoir permis ce
débat sur ce sujet pas de vérité absolue
mais rien n'indique que la vaccination
obligatoire soit le dernier recours en
conséquence le groupe écologiste h1ni
min et 23 contre l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi merci
touarga
madame cohen vous avez la parole pour un
5 minutes et pour le groupe s'est
resserré
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la lutte
contre le coc vide 19 passe par une
couverture vaccinale de l'ensemble de la
population en france en europe et dans
le monde nous saluons la découverte en
un temps extrêmement court de vaccin
contre ce virus très contagieux et
dangereux obtenir le meilleur taux de
couverture vaccinale de l'ensemble de la
population le plus vite possible est un
objectif que nous partageons toutes et
tous dans cet hémicycle et les derniers
chiffes de kovy traqueur sont assurant
le cap des 50 millions de françaises et
français primo vacciner a été franchie
le 6 octobre dernier soit 75 4% de la
population alors que 73,1 % reçu les
deux doses requises ce sont des moyennes
les situations sont inégales avec des
taux plus faibles dans les territoires
ultramarins
sans parler de certains pays où l'accès
au vaccin quasi inexistant c'est
pourquoi pour nous il est indispensable
de mener de front la bataille en faveur
de la levée des brevets des vaccins afin
qu'ils profitent à l'ensemble de la
planète c'est dans ce contexte que nos
collègues socialistes que je remercie on
dit ont déposé cette proposition de loi
visant à rendre la vaccination contre le
coc vite 19 obligatoire pour toutes les
personnes majeures au groupe sérieux
nous estimons que la persuasion et plus
efficace que la contrainte et les
sanctions financières que veut
introduire le rapporteur les raisons
pour lesquelles des personnes
aujourd'hui non pas leur parcours
vaccinale complet sont multiples parmi
elles on retrouve de nombreuses
personnes âgées isolées à leur domicile
que signifierait pour elle une
obligation vaccinale pour convaincre les
personnes non vaccinées il faut mener
une véritable campagne de prévention
nationale qui multiplie les actions qui
consistent à aller vers pourquoi les
plus de 80 ans sont ils tous vaccinés en
espagne au portugal et pas en france
concernant l'obligation vaccinale le
président du conseil d'orientation de la
stratégie vaccinale alain fischer a lui
même reconnu que la priorité est de
vacciner les personnes vulnérables qui
se trouve en périphérie du système de
santé et de préciser que pour toucher
les 14% de plus de 80 ans encore nous
lisez et les personnes précaires ou
obèses éloigné des soins l'obligation ne
changerait rien la seule façon de
réussir à les protéger prêts à aller les
chercher quasiment une par une grâce aux
médecins traitants aux infirmières aux
associations fin de citation en outre
l'obligation vaccinale va renforcer les
inégalités sociales et territoriales de
santé comme le disait récemment jérôme
martin co fondateur de l'observatoire de
la transparence dans les politiques du
médicament je le cite attribué à
l'individu la responsabilité pleine et
entière de son comportement sans
apporter le soutien par une réelle
politique de compensation des inégalités
de santé est vouée à l'échec
l'adhésion et le respect des mesures par
la population dépendent fortement de la
crédibilité des gouvernements et de la
confiance réciproque entre les autorités
et la population
il est tout à fait regrettable que le
gouvernement ait fait de la vaccination
un enjeu politique alors que c'est un
enjeu de santé publique
pour notre part nous estimons que la
question qui nous est posée pour 20 cas
pandémie n'est pas l'obligation
vaccinale mais les tops donc système de
santé mis à mal depuis près de 20 ans
comment améliorer l'accès aux soins des
publics les plus éloignés alors que les
déserts médicaux en zones urbaines comme
rurales entraîne des renoncements
comment éviter la saturation des
hôpitaux alors que cent mille lits ont
été fermés en 20 ans pour réaliser 9
milliards d'euros d'économies et que ça
mille 700 lits ont été supprimés en 2020
comment rassurer la population sans
avoir la maîtrise de la production de
médicaments dont les vaccins par un pôle
public de médicaments et des dispositifs
médicaux voir s'envoler les profits des
labos en pleine crise sanitaire
économique et social est indécent et
sèment le doute parmi les populations
comment faire en sorte que des
professionnels ne quitte pas le chemin
de l'hôpital épuisé par les conditions
de travail qu'ils vivent dépité d'avoir
été applaudi hier et stigmatisé
aujourd'hui par la loi du 5 août 2021
sur la gestion de la crise sanitaire qui
a rendu la vaccination obligatoire pour
elle j'ai eu avec en cas de refus une
suspension immédiate de leur contrat de
travail sans rémunération
comment ne pas s'inquiéter sur ces
milliers de suspension qui entraîne des
tensions dans les établissements qui mal
qui manque déjà cruellement de personnel
ainsi par exemple l'hôpital de mulhouse
qui a dû déclencher le plan blanc pour
réquisitionner le personnel disponible
ou encore certains départements ultra
marins où la loi ne peut être appliquée
sous peine de fermeture des
établissements hospitaliers
l'impératif de santé publique nécessite
une véritable révolution copernicienne
de notre système de santé avec un
financement qui soit sûr et selon les
besoins personnels en lits d'hôpitaux en
hôpitaux de proximité
henson et non selon des objectifs de
réduction des budgets publics la grande
majorité du groupe sérieux votera contre
cette proposition de loi
car si nous partageons l'objectif d'une
couverture vaccinale la plus large
possible vous l'aurez compris nous
préférons une forte adhésion de la
population à la contrainte je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci la parole est maintenant un homme
indien sur le groupe pour 8 minutes et
pour le groupe union centriste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de
commission monsieur le rapporteur je
tiens tout d'abord à adresser un message
de soutien à notre collègue patrick
kanner et à son groupe qui dans une
situation de crise inédite ont fait une
proposition logique méritant un débat de
fond éclairer un échange d'arguments
construit et en aucun cas le déferlement
de menace intolérable qui ne font que
brouiller le débat de ce 13 octobre
mon message suivant ira si je puis me le
permettre à tous ceux qui croient
qu'avec des milliers de mails une
avalanche d'invectivés autant de tapage
en influence le vote d'un sénateur
nous ne légiférons ni à l'audio maître
ni au sonomètre
je respecte profondément le droit
d'expression et le droit de
manifestation mais à tous ceux qui en
font trop je demande simplement de me
laisser m'informer à des sources fiables
et travailler sereinement dans l'unique
et constant souci de l'intérêt commun ce
préambule est en pause et j'en viens au
débat autour de l'obligation vaccinale
que nous avons déjà eu dans l'hémicycle
cet été lorsque le sénat s'est prononcé
dans sa majorité pour l'instauration du
pass sanitaires et la vaccination
obligatoire pour les soignants deux mois
après ce vote est la mise en place de
ces mesures le groupe socialiste propose
de nouveau d'étendre l'obligation
vaccinale à l'ensemble de la population
de plus de 12 ans en effet il apparaît
que la courbe des vaccinations
s'infléchit et que son risque rythme
ralenti notablement mais je suis
surprise qu avant de proposer une mesure
radicale venant à l'encontre de ce qui
vient d'être mis en place nous ne
prenions pas le temps d'une analyse
approfondie des causes de ce phénomène
de ralentissement vaccinale car enfin
est-il prudence de s'attaquer aux
comment sans avoir bien étudié le
pourquoi j'ai relu avec attention tous
les arguments et auditions du rapport de
monsieur jonnier et je n'ai pas trouvé
de réelle analyse des réticences
vaccinale je me souviens je me souviens
pourtant bien du professeur delfraissy
nous disons en audition il faut
profondément essayer de comprendre et
respecter les tertio vaccinale il y à
bien dans le rapport une synthèse
exhaustive des opérations d'aller vers
dont on ne sait pas d'ailleurs lesquels
sont encore en cours et lesquels ont été
interrompu les opérations de vaccination
d'entreprise en milieu scolaire ou
universitaire au plus près des personnes
en hébergement d'urgence dans les
prisons squats ou bidonvilles mais
j'aurais aimé lire pourquoi certains ont
refusé le vaccin et dans quelles
proportions ont-ils été touchés
approcher quel retour sur ce point des
ambassadeurs de la vaccination les 700
personnes en cdd recrutés pour assurer
les campagnes d'aller vers à l'heure où
chacun de nous est constamment ce sont
des je m'étonne qu'on ne les ait pas
interrogé sur ce point capital on peut
imaginer que la dernière poche de
résistance est composé d anti vaccins
fermement opposées au vaccin quelle
proportion représente t-il mais je note
également dans ce rapport qu'une part
non négligeable des personnes de plus de
80 ans demeurent éloignés de la
vaccination avec des situations
d'isolement aggravée par des difficultés
d'accès à un médecin traitant et se
trouverait en situation de mort sociale
ce qui m'inspire trois remarques
premièrement cette ppl creuserait alors
une inégalité sociale ce qui n'est pas
l'objectif et furets de ces personnes
âgées isolées en plus du reste des hors
la loi
deuxièmement il ya fort à parier que
loin des 4 cercles que sont la famille
les amis le voisinage et les réseaux
associatifs je cite le rapport ces
personnes soient de pauvres vecteurs de
maladies car il n'en pas grand monde à
qui la transmettre une obligation
vaccinale ne résoudra en rien leur état
de non vaccinés qui relève plutôt de
difficultés sociales et logistiques
auxquels nous pouvons collectivement
travailler
[Musique]